okay what I'm going to talk about today
is a topic in b1 all about genetics now
within this topic there's lots of
keywords so we're just making sure that
we know and we're confident what all of
these different words mean so first of
all we have DNA in all of our cells in
our body
it contains this double helix shape
that's the kind of like a twisted ladder
shape molecule called DNA which contains
all the genetic information about how to
make anything in your body a section of
this DNA is called a gene now what this
section is is it's a code a list of
instructions of how to make any protein
in the body if we have this particular
gene here this gene could be for eye
color it could be how to make a
particular enzyme then we could make
that particular protein now you inherit
your genes from your mother and your
father and so you'll have one gene about
let's say eye color from one parent and
another gene about eye color from
another parent so these are different
versions of the same gene also known as
alleles so let's say you've got your you
have this allele for brown eyes from
your mother and this allele for blue
eyes from your father now the one where
the capital letter is denoted like this
because it is dominant this means we
only need one of this allele for this to
be expressed in the phenotype we'll get
to what that means in a second if it's
lowercase this shows that it's recessive
this means that we need two of this
allele for this to be expressed in the
phenotype so first of all we have the
term that we need to know called
genotypes now genotype is just the type
of genes that you have so this here
could be your genotype because you have
this gene this particular allele and
this gene this particular allele
remember alleles are just different
versions of the same gene in this case
for eye color this person here would
have brown eyes because brown eyes this
way this allele here is dominant which
means this person we have brown eyes
however if this person had this genotype
type of genes this person would have
blue eyes because they have two
recessive alleles meaning they have blue
eyes now another term we need to know or
two terms rather are heterozygous and
homozygous now the way that I always
remember this is this
I think of heterosexual relationships
and homosexual relationships
heterosexual relationships are between a
man and a woman so it's people of
different sexes and so heterozygous
genotype means that you have different
alleles one dominant and one recessive
homozygous relationships are of two
people of the same sex in this case this
is how it relates to this so we have two
alleles which are the same so this is
homozygous recessive the last keyword we
really need to know is the phenotype now
what the word phenotype means is how it
physically looks on the outside now what
I mean by that is if someone has this
genotype of two recessive alleles for
blue eyes their phenotype how it will
physically look is they have blue eyes
this person's phenotype because they
have that dominant allele this person's
phenotype is that they have brow
eyes that is most of the genetic key
terms that we need to get our heads
around thank you